all right cellular respiration includes
the metabolic pathways of glycolysis the
krebs cycle and the electron transport
chain as represented in the figure so we
have the figures here of
glycolysis the krebs cycle and the
electron transport chain if all of this
looks completely foreign to you i
encourage you to watch the videos on
khan academy on glycolysis the krebs
cycle and the electron transport chain
and on and on cellular respiration in
general all right let's tackle this
problem there's a nice review of all of
those things in cellular respiration
carbohydrates and other metabolites are
oxidized meaning electrons are taken
away from them
and the resulting energy transfer
reactions support the synthesis of atp
all right
using the information above describe one
contribution of each of the following in
atp synthesis
all right the first one catabolism of
glucose in glycolysis and pyruvate
oxidation the second was oxidation of
intermediates in the krebs cycle and the
third one is formation of a proton
gradient by the electron transport chain
now each of these statements seem kind
of intimidating but they're really just
saying describe how glycolysis and
pyruvate oxidation contribute to atp
synthesis describe how the krebs cycle
because the krebs cycle is essentially
nothing but the oxidation of these
intermediates to produce things that are
useful for atp synthesis and then the
formation of the of the proton gradient
by the electron transport chain well
that's what the electron transport
that's what the electron transport chain
does it takes high energy electrons from
nadh or fadh2 and then as those the high
energy electrons go to lower and lower
energy states it's pumping these
hydrogen protons across the membrane
when they come back in that's used to
synthesize atp so let's just answer it
we have to describe one contribution of
each so let's first focus on glycolysis
so if we look here there's more than one
contribution you see that it can
phosphorylate these two adps to two atps
so that's one contribution we could list
we could say that it's producing
these nadhs
it's producing these nadhs which can
provide the both the hydrogen proton and
more importantly the high energy
electrons for the electron transport
chain later on you see that right over
here
or you could say that well look it's
producing the acetyl coa which can enter
the krebs cycle which is used to produce
gtp or more nadhs or fadh2s so all of
these are contributions and since we
only have to list one i'll list the most
direct and obvious one although you
could list any of these
is
i will list
since they say one contribution i'll say
the phosphorylation
phosphorylation
of two
adps
two adps to
two atps
two two
atps and i could list several more but
that's a that's a good one right over
there we just have to have one
contribution all right oxidation of
intermediates in the krebs cycle
so the oxidation of the intermediates
that's just talking about each of these
things keep getting oxidized and as they
get oxidized we can use that to reduce
other things including
nad plus 2
nadh so when you reduce it you're it's
gaining electrons notice nad plus is
positive and it becomes nadh which is
neutral and these nadhs are used later
on in the electron transport chain to
to
pump hydrogen protons across the
membrane which are then used in
oxidative phosphorylation to produce the
atp as they go back through the membrane
so you could talk about the nadhs or
fadh2s or you could talk about the
direct creation of gtps which could be
used to create atps so any of that is
fine so i'll just list one of them
so
i'll write
reduction
of nad plus
to nad
nadh
which
is used
in electron transport chain
in
electron
transport
chain
to pump hydrogen protons
to get
to create proton gradient to create
proton
gradient
gradient and once again i could talk
about the gdp the the gt
the gtp is being created i could talk
about the fadh2 being created
formation of a proton gradient by the
electron transport chain
well as the
as the protons flow flow with the
gradient back into back across the
membrane they
they power atp synthase which creates
atp from adp
so
as
protons
flow
across membrane
flow with gradient across membrane flow
with
gradient
across membrane and if you're actually
taking the ap test you might want to
just do it below so you might have more
space but i'll just fill it in here as
protons flow with gradient across
membrane
they drive
atp synthase
which
takes we can say oxidatively
phosphorylates so i'll just write
phosphorylates
adp
a
d
p to
atp and once again if everything i'm
saying here sounds foreign and if these
diagrams don't make a lot of sense to
you if they don't trigger a a
pleasurable memory in your head i
encourage you to watch the videos on
khan academy hopefully you'll get a
little bit more intuition for for the
things that i am
talking about all right now let's see if
we can tackle part part b
use each of the following observations
to justify the claim that glycolysis
first occurred in a common ancestor of
all living organisms so nearly all
existing organisms perform glycolysis
so it's much more likely
so much
more likely that this in order for this
to happen maybe i'll write this
in order so for this one right over here
in
order
for
this
to be the case to be
the case
it
is much more likely
much
more
likely
that
this
evolved
in a common ancestor
in common
ancestor
and was passed down
or you could say selected for even
and selected for
selected for
rather
than
independently coming about multiple
times then independently
independently
arising in multiple branches of the of
the evolutionary chain then ran then
independently
arising
in multiple branches
branches
of tree of life
or let me say
multiple branches of evolutionary tree
evolutionary
tree the fact that all nearly or they're
saying nearly all
nearly all existing organisms perform
glycolysis in theory they could it could
have happened independently just because
this gets selected so far strongly but
if something but if something happens in
nearly all organisms it's very likely
that it evolved in a very very early
stage at a kind of a primitive ancestor
organism and that was selected for and
it continues to be selected for and
that's why we continue to see it
all right glycolysis occurs under
anaerobic conditions so actually let me
create some space here so i don't things
don't get too jumbled up so glycolysis
occurred occurs under anaerobic
conditions well early earth
early
earth
had little
had little oxygen
little oxygen
in
atmosphere
early life
so early life
had to
had to perform had to i guess you could
say
produce atp or
early life had
to metabolize
metabolize
sugars or carbohydrates in anaerobic
environment
in
an aerobic so in an environment that
doesn't have oxygen anaerobic
anaerobic
environment
so that seems to once again justify the
claim that glycolysis first occurred in
a common ancestor of all living
organisms
glycolysis only occurs in cytosol
so
so most so earliest
earliest
life
didn't
have
membrane-bound organelles
membrane
bound
organelles
so
the fact that it only occurs in size xl
so fact
that
occurs
in cytosol
consistent with
it'd be that it's possible that that
early life did it
is consistent
that er with early life
with
it
first occurring
occurring in common ancestor first
with it first occurring
at first occurring
in common
early
ancestor
i'll then tackle parts c and d in the
next video